hello and welcome to this video ok I'm
going to try to get some of my rating
back against NIMS uzo after I have
gifted away a lot of points in the game
before but simply overstepping the time
unnecessarily
it's almost necessary but it's always
unnecessary is what I'm trying to say
but there was a really really awful way
of losing on time okay what is my
opponent doing him we have Oh what we
have a electrons that's a candy that's
the kind of chess I can never believe in
play completely without any pawn
structure it feels it feels a lot like a
hector's on the board ones it isn't so
easy actually the a to pawn this is a
digital room I had this on the board
once and it is it's like the same thing
all over again
during that game I thought okay what leg
is doing is just in in total rubbish and
then you look at it again and it's not
so easy okay I don't want you give up
sees a to just yet by allowing him to
take and then I don't take on a to this
pawn structure is still absolutely
terrible
okay inserting that must be okay is he
going age five I cannot believe it
okay ninety-four it's a kind of a double
attack at xg5 if it takes g6
ya have to do that I cannot there's no
way I'm not playing this you know what
and it's still somewhat murky and if
this is a really strong Bishop g7 it is
just this is just what it is and I
cannot easily take on the six because a2
is hanging h6 is a strong move
I have to prevent d5 just have to do it
I have a bad feeling about this
yeah sometimes those games where you
feel hmm it looks really hot and
everything but Wow
did Bishop one g7 and the a farm I mean
it's a structure and then yeah this is
really bad but the pieces are super
active something that must be oh maybe
it's okay but like maybe more than okay
we don't know and I haven't cancelled
yet which is always unsettling me I
would definitely like to guess oh but I
didn't have the time you just didn't
have the time
maybe I could have played 15 Bishop d3
or something like that okay I'm happy
that he's spending a bit of time that is
really using using my task a little bit
yeah maybe he can play like a Queen to
e7 or something and like Knight takes
it's tough to play because of rook t8
yeah and if I take d6 with the Queen a 2
is hanging and his he's also tried to
move the bishop and attack my knowledge
hmm now that is absolutely a viable move
26 rook a to that that is just not good
at all
96 property 8 I don't want to do that I
just don't but what am i doing
castling he's taking on h3 and I have to
play a move here I'm just cannot Bishop
age 3 I play Knight g5
okay
let's stop d5 I mean now Bishop c3 is
not on the agenda anymore and maybe I
can play 95 yep
the absolute best would be a trait trade
those please trade the bishops so that I
get the light squares for forever
you can play Quinta f7 which is a little
bit and annoying sight trying to put a
claim b3 and I should think about it for
a moment here because I have a bit of
time he's got ten seconds I've got
thirty
Oh
that was stupid that was a really stupid
blunder how can i blunder there that's
it's really really awful
23
well those cones could be really
dangerous
okay t3
okay who I was talking I mean honestly I
think the opening I must refute somehow
but I don't didn't do it and he played
very I think very actively and
interestingly after that so you can
definitely argue about d5 but it looks
it looks very straightforward
or is this the position when I teach
three is so strong I tend to forget it
1993 year there was one of one one line
where f5 was answered with node h3
impossible I'm interested though in the
position like like how it went like this
I developed and after f4 a hat is on the
board I'm absolutely certain
about that
and Bishop takes I should be told cam
black is fine I mean he's so active him
very interesting I probably have to play
this early night h3 or some more improve
along here this is probably correct but
they still be fired that cannot be true
yeah this is right what did he do
each hive Cape 96 maybe Knight f3 here
to get this
well it's possible so quite sharp anyway
the game had so many interesting moments
og5
I stopped it from the moment King h8 the
night before isn't so great you know I
should cast I'll probably add d5 was
possible it's it's something that I've
thought about but could couldn't quite
believe yeah but it's tough here he's
threatening age six this this piece has
no square and if I take probably cream
shakes and cream shakes he's super
active him it's possible that the two
bishops headed I'm losing both pots and
then my position definitely sucks oh I
would have been strong g5 would have
been strong you and aged six here up t1
Queen e7 I was I think a good North 93
yeah this is this is probably stronger
yeah yeah that is stronger I was
panicking a little bit
this is better I mean okay this kind of
shows that 94 was a failure but I should
still do it here after castling I was
thinking if he takes him that I wanted
to grab this one is that so bad a happy
ship c8 whoa
you know I thought this could be quite
okay for me it isn't okay it isn't okay
he does that yeah so that was a clear
opportunity for him to be be a lot
better now after Knight c3 I think I'm
okay again I mean here we probably made
a couple of mistakes simply because of
the time and this now is extremely nice
for white hopefully didn't quite Oh
quite happy with it with up to here a 95
is good yeah that's true I was thinking
about getting the Queen's of the board
and I mean we have to take into account
of time this is a big blunder of Ostia I
just didn't see that after the pawn
capture the Queen was all of a sudden
attacking this I should play 95 and now
things have shifted into a situation
where it's probably equally for
Oh Luke age six oh wow that would have
been a problem I have to play King G 1
okay King F 1 was a very stupid move man
I should play rook easy one of course
yeah just get them
Luke traded I mean again around here we
both didn't have much time Tim if 3 F 3
is what is what he has to do
here this is just just going to be week
yet he has to play looking for huh I
didn't actually see that that he can
take here and then I'm not willing
probably very tough game and I really
think I had this on the board the same
easy wave we need to do that she
unleashes exactly this position I had on
the board game found
it shows
headache l against the same person
against the same guy that's interesting
it must be this game oh yeah so he's got
this worked out I played this that also
wasn't very convincing okay by now it is
convincing but that was better than this
game so I didn't really improve or learn
anything from the first one I mean at
least I remembered that I had on the
board before okay guys thanks for
watching